let me start by asking you just about
the importance of this trip of coming to
the United States why has the Pope
decided to do in well he was invited to
the world meeting of families that was
your original invitation he wanted to be
there in philly for that and he made a
larger trip so and he's getting to
address the UN address Congress so he's
really making the most of this time here
so that's going to capture a lot of
headlines he going before Congress how
big a deal is that and what you expected
the same well no Pope has ever addressed
Congress in fact very few popes have
addressed national assembly so this is a
big deal it's going to be very
interesting as we know he can be very
frank and direct so the question is is
he going to lecture the congressional
representatives I don't think so I think
he's going to challenge them I think
he's going to try to give them a sense
of hope but also you know question some
of their decisions and I hope everybody
will leave feeling challenged in some
way Garry wills had a wonderful piece in
The Boston Globe today talking about how
there are kind of two churches and you
look at this particular Pope and the
role that he plays trying to bridge both
of them it's a very delicate act it
sounds like it'll be very delicate act
yes yes I mean you still have that a
little bit in Cuba how he tre he's very
diplomatic you know he knows for example
in Cuba he met with Castro but there a
lot of people pushing for him to push
more on the questions of Human Rights he
backed away from that a little bit so I
think he knows that he has to be
diplomatic here so I think he will be a
little bit careful in his remark we
focus on the big events the masses in DC
in New York and Philadelphia but he'll
be doing other things you'll be paying
close attention to this absolutely we're
very interested in kind of the smaller
meetings he'll be having he's going to a
school in Harlem he's going to a prison
in philly Catholic Charities in DC these
are sort of in his wheelhouse these kind
of personal encounters especially with
people he's asked to meet with people
immigrants people from poorer
backgrounds so it'll be very interesting
to see what happens there there was such
a burden to expectation that this Pope
would do more to get people who have
maybe left the church to come back
recruit new people to the church how's
he doing it hasn't been that long how's
he doing so far yeah it's only been two
and a half years and the signs have been
good people seem certainly intrigued
with this Pope and I think there's a
poll today said that his popularity
ratings are very high like near like
John Paul two numbers whether people are
actually getting back in the pews that
may take longer people are considering
it but it doesn't seem like they've
committed yet just lastly I won't ask
about the means by which he's doing that
one of which is through Twitter I think
it at pontifex so there many of us have
now in our feeds how successful is he
been with with social media enormous
well I think he has nine languages he's
tweeting in I just learned the other day
that he actually approves most of the
tweets before they go out so this isn't
some underling do it they bring it to
him he signs off on it so he's very
involved in that